Irina Shayk flaunts her post-baby body  and not one but two see-through looks  it's like unbelievable  [Music]  the 31 year old Russian supermodel and  Bradley Cooper's baby mama stepped out  in kanne France on Wednesday for the  20th birthday of lore'l event looking  confident and stunning in this black  mesh gown with a bandeau top and  matching high waist bottoms underneath  with a zipper embellishment to up the  back she paired the look with strappy  black and gold heels with her hair  pulled back into a low bun arena also  attended the be gilded screaming earlier  in the day rocking this sheer ensemble  with black striped detailing in a thick  black belt I was really excited the day  before the new mom shut it down in this  gorgeous canary yellow gown marking her  first red carpet since giving birth she  and Bradley welcomed their first child  of baby girl  Lea in March  you